all right Chantal
Chantal uh where are you from originally
where'd you grow up I grew up well I'm
originally from Salinas California but I
grew up in Bakersfield I moved out there
when I was 10. what was your family like
our family
um so I had my dad and my stepmom
growing up
I lost my real mom when I was 10. and so
basically my dad and his wife were the
ones
um raising us how'd you lose your mom
she was sick so yeah
and how do you describe your childhood
my childhood was
I mean it was good it was you know I
went through some stuff
um
but I don't like what I went through
like you know
I wouldn't say that I had a bad
childhood because of it but I did go
through a lot of stuff that a lot of
the girls that you know are on your
channel say that they go through you
know the abuse and stuff
um you're closer to your mom or your dad
actually I'm not really close to both I
was more close to my grandma
yeah
she stepped in when your mom passed away
yeah well she was always in the picture
because my dad would always travel for
work and stuff but
yeah she was the one that held it down
whenever my dad wasn't present what were
you like in high school
um I was kind of bad I was a very
curious like
I was really curious and
um
my dad and my stepmom are really strict
so I feel like that kind of just made me
like even more Curious and made me want
to you know just go do more just because
they were trying to stop me from living
like a certain way so it just made me
want to live like that even more and
Chase all the things that they were like
trying to keep me away from and whatnot
but yeah I was um
it's kind of bad you graduated yeah I
did though and after you graduated would
you like to go from there
so after I graduated I actually
um
I moved back up north with my grandma
for a few months and I had actually
signed up for college and was done to go
to college but
I just didn't and
um
yeah I was out there for a few months
just working I was working a regular job
and
I decided that I wanted to move back to
Bakersfield I missed my siblings I
missed my friends I just missed my life
and so I moved back to Bakersfield and
um I wasn't living back at home anymore
with my parents I had already moved out
and um
I really didn't have anywhere to go and
so I started stripping I was still
working like a regular square job but I
started stripping and
yeah
how long do you work at the club I was
only there for a few months actually
probably like six months
and
and that was the introduction to
craziness
which is
um I base I basically got introduced to
the game because I was you know dancing
and stuff
um
but then
I stopped stripping because my parents
ended up finding out and even though I
was already grown
they still like they were so strict that
they made me move back home like I left
my apartment I left obviously my job I
left everything behind I didn't have
anything I don't have any money I didn't
have
anything and so I moved back home and
then I found out I was pregnant and my
whole life changed but for the greater
but you started working as an escort
so when I was stripping
that's when I got introduced to it yes
um but that wasn't like something that I
was doing all the time it was just like
here and there if that makes sense
how long were you doing that kind of
stuff
um that was very short-lived well at
that time so then like how I started got
pregnant I completely changed like my
whole entire life I went full-blown
Square bear like I was
basically a stay-at-home mom playing
housewife and you know raising the
babies and stuff
and then
um my children's died and I
excuse me we decided to go our separate
ways and
um
yeah our breakup at first like it wasn't
easy you know we just
both went and did our own thing and I
was kind of left with
the bills like
I had this man taking care of the bills
I had him taking care of everything and
then one day all that just stops and so
you know I had to go make it happen and
I had to use my resources and what I
know and that's when I just like
kind of dip my foot back in the game and
you know just did it whenever I needed
to it wasn't like I was just out there
like full-fledged you know
but um
yeah
and you've been doing it now for how
long since then
so
I did it off and on for a few months and
then
um I really just stocked all my money
like I told myself I didn't want to do
that for so long so I was just going to
stock my money stock my money and
um I did that and then that's when I got
hit with my grandma passing away and so
I was just like in a really dark space
and so
um
I was just glad that I was focused for
those few months and stacking my money
because I wasn't able to go out and make
any money I wasn't
even worried about talking to anybody
like I was just in such a dark space
that
I I couldn't do anything for myself so
um yeah I was basically living out of my
savings for two and a half years
yeah
but at the same time like
those two and a half years were very
necessary for me like my growth my just
everything and your kids
what about them
you were you were raising them the whole
time right well I mean their dad was
still in the picture so you know we
would take turns and stuff
um whenever they would go to their dads
that's when I would go and you know do
what I had to do and stuff
how do you feel about doing that kind of
work some girls like it some girls
just just deal with it right
um
I used to hate it like I I really did
used to hate it but I realized it was
because of the way that I was
approaching it and the way that I was
basically like
just doing it like I back then I just
was so reckless and you know was doing
anything for money whether that be like
it's just you know living too fast and
then when I took those two and a half
years off I
really went through like
I went through something I've never been
through it was really deep I went
through like this spiritual awakening
almost well not almost or was that but I
went through like the spiritual
awakening
and
um
I just realized that
I was living wrong well the way that I
was
like approaching that lifestyle back
then it was approaching it wrong and I
realized that if I was going to do this
type of work I was gonna have to apprent
approach it with a different like
approach it differently with intention
approach it in a way that
even though
like this work is frowned upon or
whatever I could approach it in such a
way that
I wasn't going to be dealing with like
all the other bad stuff that I used to
deal with or like
you know I wasn't attracted since I
wasn't moving bad I wasn't really
attracting bad but that doesn't mean
that things still don't happen to me
just because I'm not out there like what
kind of things have you learned
I've learned a lot things that
School can't even teach you
um
but yeah I've learned that it's all
about intention if you're out there
moving and this is just with everything
in life if you're out there just moving
with the wrong intention or no intention
at all you're just doing it just to do
it or just for like the fast money
you're not going to get anywhere and if
anything like
that money you're not even going to see
that money if you're out of alignment
you're just gonna
not have any sense of control with it
I've been there
you saved money I do yeah I do drugs
drugs were not part of your life no I
mean I smoke weed yeah and I do shrooms
here and there but like other drugs no
yeah
the heavy addictive drugs are what can
take you down oh yeah you think you're
making a lot of money yeah I have seen
that firsthand um
I am going through that actually with my
brother like and his you know drug
addiction
and yeah it's really hard I've
seen my brother's life like drastically
change right in front of my eyes
and
yeah it's really crazy
so you learned a way to play this game
and do it intelligently right I feel so
yeah
and that makes it safer
it does but like I said that doesn't
mean that I still don't go through stuff
out there like I've been through stuff
like
actually just two weeks ago I'm not
gonna get too into detail but
um
I got robbed two weeks ago and
that was another moment I haven't had
anything really bad happen to me since I
got back in the game
last year but
this was like the first situation that
really had me like
damn why am I even doing this still like
I kind of just want to be done but then
you realize like
as messed up as it sounds like that's
just what comes with this lifestyle like
you could either accept it or you could
just get out
but
there's not a whole lot of jobs where
you're gonna get robbed like that right
right
but then again you know what I don't
take it as oh I just take it as a lesson
I know you know what I have to do now I
I'm already super pretty cautious but
you know sometimes you kind of just slip
up a little bit and
yeah but I definitely learned um
but I mean we're all gonna go through
things in life not just because
you're in this lifestyle like of course
you are prone to go through more things
but
yeah I just like to look at it like you
know what
it is what it is
they ask you how old you are yeah I'm 27
27. yeah if you had your life to live
over again what would you have done
differently
honestly nothing
at all those mistakes you made were just
part of the learning process right right
I feel I'm a firm believer and
everything happens for a reason even the
bad like
everything happens for a reason
but yeah I wouldn't change anything I
don't regret anything I feel that
you know everything that I went through
is what made me the woman that I am
today and I'm really proud of the woman
that I am
still and I know I'm I'm only continuing
to
you know get better and learn more and
just Elevate myself so
yeah I don't regret anything
I love my life emotionally what do you
go through
doing a lot a lot that's one thing that
I'm not gonna hide is it hard on a woman
it is of course of course
um
I would say that back then it
even though it was hard and it would
affect me I feel like back then I was
just so Cutthroat and like really didn't
give a damn about anything to the point
where I was just like and whatever even
like when the bad would happen I would
never take time to really like sit down
and evaluate
everything and really like pay attention
to okay what can I do different why did
this happen to me what could I do
to not let this type of stuff happen to
me you know in the future
I mean everything we do in life you pay
a price for right what are the prices
you pay for doing this kind of work
the prices that I pay I would have to
say
is
I dealt with a lot like with my family
like my parents my dad and my stepmom
still because they don't accept what I
do they are not in favor of this type of
work or this lifestyle like they
constantly
are like begging me to stop you know so
I have to deal with my family being her
my family always constantly worrying
sending that like energy to me
when
I don't want to deal with that I want
people to just like
support me no matter what I do whether
I'm you know a brain surgeon whether I'm
an escort whether I'm you know working
at Nasa it doesn't matter I just want my
family most importantly to just support
me so that kind of sucks like just
dealing with that you know and
um
also
like just eventually that my kids
knowing that you know I'm doing this but
at the same time
I'm such an active and present mother
that
I'm not even really worried about my
kids ever looking back and being like
wow that's some crazy that our mom
did you know like because I still handle
business a lot of people feel it should
be legalized it should and that might
take the stigma away from it right I
think that it should I mean
you'd be surprised who are the ones out
here you know buying the ones that
are making these you know
uh
what do you call it
just all the laws and everything the
politicians those are the main ones
really a lot of your clients are married
I take it yes they are yeah yeah
what have you learned about men from
doing this kind of work a lot it's my
favorite question I ask it a lot
I was just learned that
as messed up as it sounds like I I
cannot ever fully trust a man I mean
anybody to be honest but
a man
yeah
because a man can be sitting in his
wife's face every single day
take care of the Bills take care of the
family do literally everything
like
and he could still be in my hotel room
paying my bills and you know doing what
we do and go back home to that that's
disgusting to me
like
but what's your what's your dream is it
is it to find a sugar daddy that will
easier
of course I feel like deep down inside I
feel like that's every hose dream
to just
find like that security but like
somebody that
how can I explain it like
I don't want to fall off like I don't
want to ever get married or like
I of course don't want to fall for a
trick ever but
I mean if I meet somebody that I
genuinely like form a deep connection
with and we're
on the same page with a lot of things
about life and he's bringing me
security like financial and emotional
security why not
like why not
plus I don't even like to like
I don't know
I don't like to really like think too
much ahead if that makes sense
this kind of work I assume must impact
your personal relationships right if you
had have you had boyfriends at all
um I have you'd be surprised like
there's guys will accept it this is what
you do when you're not with them
so many men
like you'd be surprised at what men are
willing to put up with just to
like have a woman in his possession
whether that be like even having to pay
for or even having to you know
deal with
a girl busting dates or having her you
know tricks on the side whatever like
having your phone blow up all through a
date right I can't and knowing every one
of those cars right I can't do that like
I've had
I just I'm done like I I don't date
anymore like for like for fun and love
and all that I don't do it like while
I'm doing this type of work I have to
stay focused on this only because once I
start letting all that other stuff come
into this
it just becomes a whole mess it throws
everything off I'm out of alignment I
can't like I just can't be dealing with
that type of stuff like I'm on a mission
right now and I'm sticking to my mission
but are you addicted to the fast money
yeah yeah it would be hard to just quit
quit this and
become somebody's wife and not have
money being part of the transaction
right
um
I don't think I'll ever become
somebody's wife well not in my near
future maybe like
you know later but yeah but I would
think one Sex and Money become connected
which they have in in a
A Working Girl's Life
I would think that becomes very
difficult to stop yeah it is
having that kind of relationship with a
man where you're not getting taken care
of very well right I can't even do it
anymore like
like the times that I did stop doing
this and I'm like you know I'm just
gonna
not do this anymore and just live a
regular life
you just can't go back to that
like once you've been introduced and you
know experiences you just
you can't you don't go backwards
what's your biggest fear now
this sounds crazy but I don't have any
fears
none absolutely none
really yeah
have you always been that way or is it
something you've developed through years
of
being on the streets and they're not on
the streets but you're right I was about
to say uh no I'm not a straight stumper
yeah I know that um but
which no disrespect to any of the street
Stompers I respect everybody nobody but
what you're doing is
close closely related to that right
strangers are coming right I've actually
been I've been out on the out on the
track before
so I can't even knock it
when you're working as an escort on the
on the track either one
you get addicted to money
right and that's just that just becomes
hard to
pull away from right right I mean you're
doing this for your kids right right of
course is because you have children that
you're doing this because if you didn't
have kids you think you'd still be doing
it
actually
I would I know that I would you would
yeah
um
just because this is not somebody that
just anybody can do so I feel like if
you're equipped to do it and
you know you your mental is strong
enough
for you to do it and you actually
willingly want to do it
why would you not
like this is the perfect way to get you
ahead of life like it's a perfect way to
bring you Freedom when it comes to time
when it comes to
so many other things like
a hard time
stopping this to go work it a nine to
five yeah yeah that's not happening
and plus
I can't even work a nine to five I
homeschool my boys and so
um
there's not even no room for that like
the reason
why I homeschool them too is because
I just don't want my children's
upbringing in the hands of somebody else
especially people that I don't know and
I feel like nowadays just the things
that they're even teaching our kids in
school you know you have other kids who
don't have the same proper upbringing as
your kid so
you know throw them in the mix of 100
plus kids that you don't know
how they're being brought up you don't
know you know what they're teaching your
kids
I just
I can't do it so I told myself if I had
to sacrifice these years of them being
young
in order to
excuse me make sure that you know they
get the proper education that I want
them to get
then I'm gonna do that even if it
requires me like having to do this type
of work
how about your mental health how are you
affect mental uh emotionally from this
I'm not gonna lie
um
I get I feel like I get depressed
sometimes I do
um
but I would say it's because I just have
to leave my kids
like I nobody wants to be out
at 2 A.M and like even though I know
that they're safe and I know like their
dad and I that's another thing I'm
grateful for their dad and I have such a
great relationship that when I'm away I
can leave you know in peace and just
like
just be good but at the same time like
who wants who wants to be out on a date
rather than at home with their kids you
know
so
that's the part that gets me depressed
sometimes but then you know I have their
dad too like he knows what I do I'm
always on the phone with him too like
just
talking to him letting him know what I
have going on over here and what I'm up
to what I'm doing this and that and he
does a really good job at being there
for me and just you know reminding me
that this is just temporary and you know
I'm just doing what I have to do and
you know he keeps me strong and I'm very
thankful for that my friends do too like
I only have really two friends that
close friends that really know about my
lifestyle
like exactly how it is and they helped
me a lot too so I'm very grateful for my
support system surprise yeah
Chantal what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
most important lesson that I've learned
in my life would be
probably just to you know always be your
true authentic self
with
everything like every aspect and area of
your life whether you know Society
Society deems that to be frowned upon or
whatever like you are here on your
journey everyone's journey is not
supposed to look the same you just focus
on your journey and
you know keep God first and
everything will be okay in the end it
takes a lot of courage to do what you
just did right
all right let's do this like the
interview right it no seriously because
especially in your shoes yes because I
would never in a millionaires thought I
would
share my stuff
you just did all right Chantal thank you
so much for sharing your story thank you
I wish you lots of luck with your kids
thank you I appreciate that thank you